okay for those joining our livestream a
little bit later than we expected been a
complicated day this is a fairly
detailed meeting about design of Wolfram
language for the future here's the issue
if you make a plot and you say plot
square root of x x goes from minus 10 to
10 it does that which is pretty
reasonable if you say plot square root
of minus x squared it does that and it
gives no message which is kind of
confusing and I think let's see do we
have an example here I think we have an
example
what is this this is okay that time
series
let's see date list log plot of that
probably works whereas date list plot of
log of % 3 for some reason doesn't work
why doesn't that work again Brett I
would guess that log of time series
isn't doing anything well log of time
series is doing something it's just you
end up with log of quantity of n people
and ah that's right interpreted by
tailless plot because it's a
transcendental function and we write so
if you do normal of log of data
well that so if I say here normal no no
I'm saying if you do normal of log of
data then you'll see what the structure
is that
yeah that's kind of goofy okay all right
so let's take this from the top the
first thing is this behavior here where
you actually are getting nothing out
this so I'm claiming that in that case
we should generate a message because
it's completely unclear why you got
nothing out let's try another example
plot a X minus 10 to 0 to 10 for example
it'll be the same right that's really
confusing okay I think we should
generate a message that said baa baa baa
did not have numeric did not have a real
numeric value I mean we have such a
message for like an integrate did not
evaluate to a numeric value I forget
what the message is let's just try it
for this case right so this case should
give that
- little bit pompous that message but
it's a it's basically says the right
thing
yeah I mean that's basically the message
that I would propose to generate in this
case I mean I don't think anybody
necessarily disagrees with that that's
that's a first
okay good right now the more common I
mean I suppose sir if there's a possible
issue with manipulates now continue you
know there are certain magic values
which produce empty plots so that's one
possible alternative that's interesting
su so I don't think it should return on
evaluated I think it should generate the
empty plot but I think it should produce
the message and then generate the empty
plot the manipulates pink due to the
message of being great oh gosh what
would they do with a pink and show the
empty plot or would they just pink they
would think in show the empty part yes
I'm
terrible what do people think that you
know I could see cases where that would
be kind of ugly
I mean if I mean if you wrapped it in
quiet then it wouldn't necessarily know
to do that and the problem is that if
what happens okay so we all agree I
think that I think this is not a bad
case because this is the case for plot I
mean if there's a graphics okay so let's
let's consider a different case okay
which may already have some messaging
mechanism so if I say graphics of point
of a B comma point of C D it will pink
box in yogurt it's a message that tells
you that a B is not a coordinate what
the hell's that cell context backtick a
looks like a bug to me not sure all
right I think it's the fact that it's
you know you did that it's looking at
the boxes and now it's treating a as you
know trying to interpret a as a number
right the front end is trying to is
divorced from the kernel a at this point
or something you should look at that
that's pretty ugly no I understand that
but I don't understand why it's
committing itself to the context there
why is it even displaying the context I
don't think it should I think so contact
it shouldn't affect if that's what it's
going to be by default it should in
effect beyond the context path or not
display am i making sense
[Music]
who's gonna take that to the front-end
team they can take those um they think I
mean I think the other major issue is
supposed in your plot a X from 0 to 10
what happens if you give the list a
comma 1 no no no not here in I can't
like these that end of 7 yeah if you put
in a list of a and a 1 interesting I I
do think a message will be useful here
otherwise it's like where's that other
line right so if you add plot legends
goes to expression then I think you will
see both of them in the legend
[Music]
yeah okay so what's your point in this
case you wouldn't want to generate a
message I don't think it would be
harmful to generate a message well it's
not obvious well I guess my claims are
it's not a priori obvious whether or not
the tradition SH and B right because you
could not see it because you put in you
know a silly plot range right and then
it's just not in your butt and also then
I'm not sure how we necessarily detect
this so there's an indirect women the
way you're saying if you see nothing we
all agree we should give a message yeah
if you see a vestigial you know tentacle
of the thing like a legend that shows it
should have been enough no my point is
that in if you're only plotting one
function it's easy to tell whether
there's nothing in the grass yes there
if there are two things being plotted I
don't know that it's a priori easy to
tell that Brett can you comment on that
please I would have thought try sampling
each one and and you know the thing is
that just because it didn't evaluate at
one point doesn't mean that you know it
didn't evaluate any wait wait wait wait
wait you make a pass you're trying to
reduce this plot to a bunch of points
right you do that sequentially for each
of the elements of that expression list
correct
for each element of that expression list
you see whether it produced nothing over
the plot range and you know and in the
case of plots I think we should be able
to detect that an individual function
did not generate any so let's keep going
which way would you not be able to do
that I don't know I mean
130 visualization functions and yeah
they take different paths to the final
graphic okay we will talk about that but
let's okay so I think we're agreeing
that even in this case it wouldn't be
bad to have a message now if there are
eight different things I think we'll
just we'll let it go to the stop message
right if there are lots of different
ones and I'm making sense I mean I don't
know what happens here if I do this if I
say a B C here I think it treats it as a
scene nope you're yeah okay so it just
goes ahead and hits the stop message I
don't think that's terrible thoughts for
the graphics case I mean I would
probably I mean what I would probably
view is nicer is we detect if any of
them and then issue a message using the
whole thing that it contained elements
that didn't yeah that we're never
plottable okay I mean to some extent
this is getting too close to the old v5
and earlier behavior what so this is
when you know your plot of square root
of minus x squared you know would have
complained at every point yeah plot
planar you know and you were guaranteed
to hit you know general stop and and you
even got messages for that plot of
square root of x because of the minus 10
to 0 case yeah okay right all right so I
agree with you that aggregating is a
good thing okay so let's look at a
couple of other cases here okay so I
think we want to generate a message okay
so what we're agreeing is we definitely
want to generate a message where the
whole thing is blank if there is one of
the expressions is missing well no more
of the expressions are missing we would
like to generate a message but in all
cases we want to minimize the number of
messages generated now if
it's a b c where c has a valid value but
a and b don't what do we want to do that
I mean in that case the message will be
worded in a way that it will say that
ABC contained you know it at least one
component that wasn't plottable that's
lazy surely we can say yep maybe I don't
have to experiment with some things but
we might be able to okay alright so
let's go down let's look at the dateless
plot for a minute here okay I think
that's pretty much the same story for
this case here but I'm very confused by
the x-axis in this case because the
x-axis had points here why did it ignore
them so it auto scaled to the most
recent second even though this went back
to 1600 ad I think it determined that
the data wasn't plottable and didn't
even get the X ranges out of it which I
mean
provable okay
it seems desirable to improve that but
the most important thing here is
generate a message okay because at least
in this concrete one because people per
the IBM slash niste documents is a unit
that in the SI can be considered to be
having the way you won aha I'm going to
claim that's separate Michael I mean
talk about okay is Nick here okay so
let's talk about that for a minute okay
because the question is should the
visualization functions when they hit a
thing that that is has unit crud in it
try to make those substitutions in an
attempt to make it numerical
there's an argument that we need ok so
here's an interesting question if I take
that thing ok this is this is one of
these horrifying philosophical questions
you can guess what I'm going to do if I
do that should it D people if I it
I'm saying no well well normal people
are fired or is no I don't think so I
think that we have no function that D
people of eyes right now right because
the quantity isn't a outermost thing
right well I mean because the log of
people wanna t magnitude can't but isn't
the question whether so people is an
independent unit right so if you
actually try normal on that you'll get
log of the value because people are
treated as a special case unit like our
dimensionless values are so normal of
quantity three dozens becomes a pure
number and we have special cases for
special counting units and people is one
of those ones we considered similar
enough to a number that it can be
normalized and factored out interesting
so in fact if we were to put normal in
at the right place this would work in
plotting functions right so in in a five
I guess if you put a slash normal that
will presumably work no
Wynonna doesn't go deep enough because
the I see so normal okay so look this
looks to me like it's a detailed as you
were plotting that plotting has to be
able to take I don't know exactly what
the heuristic is but has to be able to
take things that have it you know
embedded quantities and try and normal
fi them well I mean what if it's not
people what if it's dollars in the case
in that case we don't factor out the
unit's we we have basically special case
handling and normal that deals with
quantities that are quote unquote
essentially numbers okay in fact in this
plot case of the dateless plot what we
might want to do is squash out the units
and just plot the magnitudes right an
indeed in dateless log plot that's
exactly what we're doing what would it
do if
add something okay hold on let's type
does that work
magnificent okay so now let me say date
list log plot of that okay that worked
why did it not show a unit on the on the
y-axis because we don't add them to
takes at the moment right I mean if you
add frame label goes to automatic
although I suppose that's a slightly
deceptive would be it slightly deceptive
yes those yes those values are dollars
so that would be correct
okay so this all just worked and it
correctly extracted units without
getting confused with log by the way um
person on a live stream prime measure Oh
odd to read maybe one comment earlier as
someone who teaches of language to
students this feature of generating
message when nothing comes out in the
plot would be very helpful by we agree
it's gonna happen second comment is
shouldn't quantity magnitude be changed
that it removes the units and I think
the point being made there is that in a
case like this right why would quantity
magnitude okay so it's an interesting
question which actually I was sort of
implicitly thinking about but not
explicitly what should that do I think
generically does the right behavior this
one is special for two cases a because
people is one of the standing unit
that's allowed to be said to one
listened users was in the and related to
the SI and the second one because look
makes it it will scarce additive what do
you mean by that I mean in I mean decide
well well generically I would argue that
any non-trivial elementary function
right cannot take anything other than
dimensionless units right that's a
rephrasing whatever did you say yes okay
let me unravel that for a second okay so
your claim is I mean sign for example
could perfectly well I mean there are
plenty of real-life cases where it takes
a time for instance no it never takes
time it takes a time times a very fair
enough okay well okay are you saying
that log is the only reasonable okay but
let's walk through this for a second um
what are some other examples of counting
units baskets did you say for food there
are plenty of counting food units what
slices
wait what about web hits for example is
that a counting unit I think so okay so
I'm trying to understand what that
percent is that I'm counting or we're
looking at dimensionless what's the
difference Michael dimensionless but
they're certainly not boy okay so normal
does that so if I take if I say I mean
that would not be an unreasonable thing
to do I mean let's say I say sine of 67
percent of pie
oh that just worked why did that work
because it
we have transcendental handling 4
dimensionless values change it into
cosine here oh because it reduced it
sorry go ahead of normal and in general
transcendental functions we have special
case handling for dimensionless values
like a dozen or percent and for angle
and satellite solid angle units so
Radian stare radians and people
otherwise we generally handle the units
as being a case where transcendental
functions don't so why did that look I
mean that did exactly the right thing
why did that work it's dimensionless the
percent is effectively just a numeric
prefix for it it's working because the
percent times pi is evaluating oh I see
that that multiplication is evaluating
yeah
okay if it was 67 web hits or something
that hits or cows or bites all right
cows are independent units cows are not
in this category right yeah it's a
different yeah what what is the
difference between a slice and a cow
Michael there is no just there's a
finite number of them that we need to
express our own things as a result for
instance in food but there of course
many many more things that one could in
principle and cows we could in principle
put in because there are probably data
in country data that gives the bottom is
number of cows yes I was just about
goats cuz you know don't we know the
number of goats in France right and this
is kind of why we we created independent
unit for counting units where you can
basically say that the qualification of
an impending unit is that it is a unit
that exists but doesn't have any
meaningful conversions you can't convert
cows to chickens
unless you want to specify some
arbitrary ratio of saying my cow a
chicken ratio is at
but so arguably that result there is
wrong like you abou that result should
be in goats yep unless the property name
is number of goats in which case it
could be a number good hmm okay but
let's imagine we had goats there then
and you want to use a visualization
function so the pure visualization
function when there is an independent
unit that will work fine correct the
only time it won't work is when you
encrust it with a log for example right
you've done you've tried to do some
transformation where that transformation
itself hasn't done anything
right okay
okay so what do we think we should do
here so the problem is what if you try
to visualize log of 10 to the 7 people
we ignore the units in that case or not
we know to ignore the units if it is a
top-level quantity object we don't know
to ignore the units if it's encrusted
and I mean we're not ignoring the units
we're just able to factor out see that
they're there and account for it right
okay so your point is if that was a okay
with a log are you saying that we can
factor yeah we can factor the unit's out
because it is an additive thing it makes
some sense to factor them out because it
would just shift the plot right
but if that was an airy function for
example it makes no sense at all to
factor out the units it's just garbage
you can't factor that all right so this
case of the log there is going to be the
unique case where this might make sense
we shouldn't try to handle it well
we could generate a custom message
because the fact is the right way to
handle it is to use the log plot
mechanism you know a log plot function
not all songs on earth no flirt
equivalents I understand that but in the
case where they do it will be super
helpful to people to tell them use the
log plot version
all right look it's a luxury feature
it's like I would if we can do it to
notice that there's a log on the outside
and say try using the log plot version
in cases where there is a log plot
version I think there will be a lovely
luxury feature other ways quote that
it's it's that now in the case of the
message for a data function what are you
gonna actually give in the output cuz
you're not gonna list every you're not
gonna go and list you know that the
10,000 points that weren't numerical I'm
making sense
right well I mean potentially it might
yeah well that's bad because we don't
want that do we
well I mean it will get handled by
dollar message preprint and so you won't
see you know a screen full of error
message you know it'll get shortened and
shallowed down to okay okay if you think
that will work fine all right can we
just have a quick review of other
visualization functions and then we
might be able to wrap up here I think
this was fairly simple can we can we
take a look where's a good list of all
those realization functions just to see
what are the horrors yeah let's start
with you know hit a couple of guide
pages so DataViz probably all roughly
the same you know whether it's the split
idea right what about a right plot array
plot doesn't need this mechanism because
it turns red doesn't it right although
if the if the entire plot is red it may
still be useful too
I agree yes I mean let's just take a
look at what that looks like
yeah that is not a very helpful that
should generate a message yes now the
other case that is obscure in that case
it's something where I'm saying you know
table 0 you know 100 100
and then I say replace part like one-one
I just do I didn't mean zero I meant a
there
that's definitely on this somewhat
obscure end of things do we care
my opinion is that's not gonna give a
message yeah I agree with you I just did
somewhat unfortunate because it's good
yeah wondering where that speck is yes
but I don't think there's a lot of
choice about that now okay time line
plot what the earth would that do here I
see that a blank time line should give a
message presumably rights now hold on a
second there's let's be clear there
could be a plot where there is nothing
where it's a perfectly valid okay let me
let me show you a different case here we
say let's plot you know random real 10
um
no 22 okay
dandy okay now we say plot range arrow
30 , 40 40 comma 50 okay now we're going
to be blank this okay what do we want to
do in this case
lack of a message or not I think
probably not I don't think so I think so
yeah I shouldn't go message because if
there's a manipulate it may often scoot
out to outside out of range
okay so here's another quick case for
you Steven which I know which way I lean
but it will see which way you lean so
Lisp lot of empty lists
you
yeah I think that shouldn't give a
message right so the message is it
looked like there should have been
something but there wasn't as opposed to
there was nothing there to start with
no dude if they're not Olivia sings the
things couldn't be plotted right you
know there were things that couldn't be
plotted not there's no output in the
results if they have them sings there's
nothing to be said okay
well I mean I could imagine somebody
wondering you know they obviously had an
upstream error that they could have had
an upstream error or this could have
been as intended right
you know most upstream errors of this
type we this is a good example of the
thing that we're hoping to develop this
exception mechanism where there are
messages that are off by default this
would be a good thing to note down if
Sushma is here maybe note it down for
the exceptions discussion as a message
that's off by default okay right I mean
so the other behavior we have right now
is if you do like bar chart of a okay
which is going to return unev al you
ated not a list just a do we want to
change that to issue in return an empty
graphic which I mean is
easy enough well I'm just think about it
I mean this part I think does the same
thing no I think that's perfectly decent
behavior I can't imagine I mean it's
just not structurally reasonable and I
tend to think this is good behavior
anybody get comment on that anybody
disagree with that statement seems
reasonable so so here's another case
okay that's is inconsistent sorry yes
and I am sure there are cases you know
that we're inconsistent okay so that
that will be the principal then that if
it's a structurally loonie then it
returns unev al you ated with a message
right so suppose you set a equal to
empty list and then you bought a what
does that have to do with anything these
functions aren't don't have hold
attributes or even plot or do you mean
perfect literally plot okay sorry I I
was jumping back to your list plot
example so I think we're probably agree
that if we had literally put the empty
list in there that we probably don't
want the message is why is it different
from this plot right ideally this should
not give a message this case even though
you're right because it evaluates it
evaluates to something which isn't
invalid I mean which it just doesn't
have everything in it that should be
fine I mean that's an implementation
this year that's not obvious because
like your statement it evaluates that's
not obvious from the documentation for a
user that's not clear that it does even
it I mean it's
point it has to evaluate Michael but at
some point yes
yes I mean and to be honest Michael I
would you know we we have code within
plot that does you know an initial trial
no sample yes but what I'm saying is
like if we don't say then be able to aid
then it's unclear for the user if there
should be a message or not if it does
able to eight then should be no message
because there's an empty list if it does
not evaluate then we have the case that
the supplied function never evaluates to
avail at clothing zinc you're arguing
you're claiming that what are you
claiming that this might evaluate to an
evaluation like if this should give a
message depends on a detail that we
don't document the data being been his a
evil related in the beginning of the
localizing X or at each x value it
depends on this we don't document that
why not even ischl II it's empty list
and and entreating give a message if it
evil it's laid out then all values
evaluated or not portable an iterative
message no because if they value it so
now you're going to claim then that if
it if a is defined instead of an empty
list as B comma one then it should not
issue a message because it evaluated to
something and all of those guys you know
and that each at least one piece of it
plotted at every point look I mean it
has to be I mean you you could know that
it has to evaluate early because if you
give a list of two things then it uses
two different colors rather than one no
it doesn't yes it does apparently you
haven't no no no we're talking about the
case where you set a equal to the list
xx squared
if it can sure okay good we're not
always evil that'll be one color right
so why does that that is really weird
that is really weird
I mean I've noticed this and I didn't
understand what knows what's happening
okay explain I don't know that I can
give a concise explanation of it but
that's my point
yes that's utterly obscure what just
happened that so everybody else want to
comment on this I mean well the answer
is that right a special case was put in
for the case where a has owned where the
expression has is a symbol which has own
values
like otherwise that you know treats it
as it's as if it's adding a single thing
that's a little bit unfortunate I mean
this would be very good if this could if
this could dig down a bit more to find
out that it's actually plotting two
things that I said we could just remove
the whole day attribute no but seriously
to what extent could you actually do
control devaluation of this and to what
extent well the modern type system for
example allow you to answer this
question I don't know enough about the
modern type system to you might raise
that with Tom see what he has to say
about it there may we may be able to get
a much closer to solving this problem
right okay I want to come back to so
that's a pretty horrifying thing I hope
that's impossible issues for plot by the
way I think something along those lines
is in the ducts okay all right so my
position about this thing about whether
it gives a message or whether it doesn't
I think we should let the chips fall as
they may
for right now we can revisit this at a
different time but you know let's let's
do whatever this will naturally do based
on what we're implementing you had a
comment on the live stream from sander
here about essentially the boss city
level flags actually we have a plan to
put in a large number of messages off by
default and use those as an as exception
mechanism um I'm not a big believer of
error level flags because having seen
that like 40 years ago in software
because it's like what's the level you
know okay to some people that's a
verbose and a relevant message to other
people that's the most important message
ever you know some messages are pedantic
and obscure and say oh that was a
complex number and other people say well
of course it was a complex number that's
no
and I don't think there's a linear
ordering of message obscurity I don't
know that anybody wants to comment on
that anybody want to comment on that
well I mean I think the other thing is
especially within Wolfram language is
you know it's like so suppose you have
feature space plot right which is
basically Lisp lot of dimension reduce
mm-hmm yeah when I'm debugging this and
you know I want to turn on you know
whatever I want to see the things coming
out of Lisp Lots you know and I don't
care what happens with dimension reduce
you know for the most part yes and you
know Matteo or at Ian's you know
probably is the opposite way yeah I
don't think the bus's levels work well I
think what will work and what I hope
we're going to be able to do is to make
an exception handling mechanism where
there are a bunch of messages that are
off by default that include things like
when a function returns aren't evaluated
and that you will be able to essentially
trap those exceptions and and basically
return if something went wrong okay
let's keep going here I'm graph block
does it have there's what what it's
weird conditions I mean not much I mean
you know so that's probably yeah it
doesn't really care what its elements
are right you know as long as rules or
something it all turned them into
vertices okay histogram it doesn't care
you know
it'll ignore you know it'll be similar
to Lisp letter bar chart angle a gauge
of a I was pretty weird
that's brazen behavior yeah so that one
would probably return on evaluated if we
follow the we should yeah I mean that's
that's just totally random what it did
them somebody's gonna say oh great my
nuclear reactor is all safe right I mean
so angular gauge you know has a separate
feature though which is if you do
angular gauge of dynamic of a
why would look at what am I gonna see
here I mean dynamic obey isn't gonna
value it either okay and so now have a
standalone dynamic of a outside okay now
drag the needle
oh goodness sake I had no idea we had
this I didn't know you could do that is
this listed in the list of controls I
don't remember if it's there or not
well it's a circular slider those are
famous we better check it's there in the
controls list in some way in some
obscure corner erased okay so what does
that do to this that's really funky hmm
what does that mean for the for the
angular gauge of ASU I don't think it
means anything I was just pointing it
out I think that you know even when you
have dynamic of a we know that there's a
dynamic there it's not like you're
sneaking it in somehow and so so what
would happen is angular gauge of dynamic
event if a is unavailing as in this case
what will it do
it will produce what it should do in
that case is produce a message then
really it shouldn't show this well I
mean I believe it's similar to a slider
of dynamic of a I see that it has to do
something right well I think it should
at least show a message although that's
not very polite behavior when it has a
dynamic this is complicated
I mean it might be possible in the case
of well I mean this might work for
angular Gage I don't know that would
work for some of the other gauges to
initialize the needle in no-man's land
sorry I lost concentration for a second
because I was working something else
could you say that again what put what
put the needle where in that no-man's
land you know pointing due south or that
would be nice I don't think there's the
world's most important thing but it
would be nice to get this right
all right okay so that's another
category here it could do and I mean I
don't think it is is the dynamic case
could force initialization but I don't
think that's what slider does until you
interact with it I don't think so either
yeah I should try it I mean we need to
figure that out yeah okay I'm looking at
a few of these others Geographics well I
think your list plot go ahead
Geographics decides whether something is
important enough to abort immediately
like your projection goes to foo or or
or it's not very important and then it
ignores it and continues so these two
moves okay and by continues okay so
let's imagine that I say cheerless plot
of a B yet that is really random if I
might say so in this case you decided to
ignore it and say well this is
equivalent to basically Geographics of
bracket bracket okay and why doesn't
Geographics a bracket bracket just give
the whole world
oh this was something we decided
initially that it believed something do
you personally I think it'd be better if
it gave the world not least because
on a computer the location is often
wrong I mean it's a thousand miles away
in my case comments about that I mean I
personally think I would not happier to
see this geo range to all I mean that
seems like a much more civilized thing
to do when you don't know where
something is rather than saying oh my
gosh in fact I you know I wants to
comment on that separately I mean you
know rather than point robbing me down
to in my particular case you know
Champaign Illinois it looks like um wine
just give the whole world you don't know
where it is give the world which I mean
I think it's what we do for you know the
extraterrestrial bodies so if you do
Geographics of you know empty lists and
geo model goes to Mars
okay are you telling me are you telling
me that we are being that is outrageous
if I might say so um so you mean if I
say to you range arrow Mars no no no but
this is something we have been
discussing recently it may still have
the older behavior
yeah because but but in fact the future
Martian settlement
so in Geographics if it doesn't know
your location because for example is no
internet connection or something
it will default to zero zero on the for
world and and here we do basically the
same thing we are different because we
all have a dollar geolocation Mars a
preferred position in Mars we are
choosing co-ceo but but this is weird
because nobody recognizes that portal so
this difference being recently changed
to the whole Mars okay so let's be
consistent and changes the whole earth
as well um is there an objection to that
well
it finds I found it a bit more in like
like like a informed the fact that we we
show the user we know where you are
donar your location I think I think the
risk is on the location is a bit
especially because when we have Networks
or VPNs etc and of course no but I and
wait a minute I don't think it's useful
I mean it is amusing to show where they
are but in the case of a okay let's
consider but a bunch of different cases
dodgy olace plot with no elements
okay I don't see how you can justify
putting a 10-mile radius on it which is
what this presumably is roughly yep well
that was it different from an empty
Geographics well let's see what an empty
Geographics does I think an empty
Geographics does the same thing exactly
which is my point
but I'm saying an empty Geographics
should also give the whole world know
that's a big change
why and I think that's the way I mean
that's the way it's been and they think
that's the way people use it really are
that reliant on the behavior I mean but
it's certainly closer to what Google
Maps does if you just go to
maps.google.com yeah but that try and do
something different I mean I mean look
at the first basic example on
Geographics we can't change it it's just
that we made this decision originally
randomly yeah more or less yeah okay
well let's think about this for a second
um I would argue that it makes much more
sense to show the whole world
I think I'm partly because of the
arbitrariness of the scale here which is
bothering me would you like it better at
100 miles no um I mean there's a very
definite okay
look maybe there is some other issues
that I'm not thinking of here but I
personally would would think that
Geographics okay so that there's two
points here first of all this case
should generate a message in my opinion
I think it should generate a message and
then show the whole world okay when our
live stream is asking message but it
should be
the same I think as an India graphics
just like an empty list plot gives you
the same thing as graphics bracket
bracket yes yeah
why does empty Geographics have street
names and cheerless plot does not
because the geophys functions don't have
labels by default for the most part
because you're typically putting stuff
on top of them and you know and I have a
whole little collection of emails of you
sending and complaining about labels
being present when my identity labels
are o true not work no there's not the
type of labels that yeah it is a matter
of your background what will change is
the Geo background we India graphics we
use street map and in the list prod we
use state map no labels so the ice
should be stigma turner happens if I say
like all here okay that's yet a
different behavior isn't it yes this is
one of these cases in which we decide
that something is it's too important to
ignore like like if you said your
graphics your projection goes to a it
would also complain of the drank output
yes it's a rental as opposed to what
list plot array does which is to return
on evaluated
he said yes that's another thing we
discussed initially here so you're gonna
fix tries to be very forgiving except
when when it decides as something is too
important if no no I understand them but
should it give a blank output or should
it return and evaluated we try to
imitate what brought to us and graphics
do this that well I mean like graphics
never returns them evaluated well I mean
it's I mean graphics only typeset so
pinks
yes this it can for example if you do
Geographics of a it will know and and
behind the map it's pink that's why
there is there really weird so if I say
to your background that's just really
weird if I might say so
oh that's just obscure as hell indeed
all right look I think there's some
cleanup necessary that let's just do a
quick scan of some of the other yeah
some of these other functions um look
the main main conclusion here is we're
not done with assist you um number line
plus I'm not even gonna ask what that
does on the unevaluated case well
actually I'm gonna ask us okay so that
does the same thing this time line plot
which is it makes a time line of a
random period of time over a short
period of time as a famous person in the
news might say why did it pick 1900 to
2020 centered on 1960 that's just
utterly obscure well I would imagine
because 1900 is the start of dates and
20th the current year round it to the
nearest decade
but even the start of dates it's
absolute time zero you know completely
arbitrary now I know that I know
okay I mean it's obviously the start of
dates was 1977 when I was born right
1970 when the UNIX operating system
thinks it is or whatever yes rendered
it's a random implementation detail but
it's an obvious consequence of you know
the document yeah I understand although
I think we're agreeing this should
return on evaluated in that's a return
on evaluated but timeline plot of empty
list I think we're saying should
evaluate to something what what about
I'm sorry
timeline plots at them to list well I
mean number lines the same whoa that's
beautiful sadly I think time line plot
was ours started out feed it to QA
that's corner case should have been
checked
so this spectacular bug if you ask me
those color swatches are really nice in
there so the thing is what I mean so
like if you do this plot of empty list
you get minus one to one in each
direction which is right is not the
default of graphics I know it's graphics
is minus one to one in both directions
okay I don't object to either of these
things but right now my question is is
there a default range for a number line
plot and time line plot that's right I
mean so if you do date list plot of an
empty list you're going to get like the
one second interval from midnight that's
a particularly goofy interval I mean I
think if you do date list plot of an
empty list just come on make
at a day or something a day or a year or
just anything other than a second
okay I think a year given the name date
list plot anybody else want to comment
on that you think a day yeah I think
it's like the most natural all right
fine and is it today
is it a moving day I would say so yes
okay it's today midnight to midnight
okay okay
number line plot I mean visually I don't
object to this it's just totally
arbitrary three-point whatever I said or
maybe minus 10 to 10 or something
or minus one to one I mean if you're
gonna do an empty one you might as well
do one that the second grader can use
for you know doing their little hops
along the number line
that's obscure it
plot range minus one to one and it only
went down to zero interesting its foot
range Frank perhaps it's referring to
something pretty good yeah it's no no I
don't think so it's I think there is a
bug yet as well is that an obviously bad
result 0 to 1 it's not obviously bad I
would still go out to 10 or something
but the hex
I mean I think what's happening is it's
detecting that it has an empty list and
short-circuiting and ignoring the plot
range all right that wasn't entirely
because I was the I went to zero okay
yeah all right I guess I'd be prepared
to go for 0 to 10 okay um what are we
doing what was the other case we had
there Oh time line plot your 1900 to
2020 now what the hell could be a lot
worse fine I mean we could do a century
on either snow though no on the inside
of the current time who cares I mean
yeah people are not thinking a century
hence unfortunately yes
okay somebody's counting the started
dates was 1977 when the first Star Wars
movie was released I thought it should
be in a galaxy long long long ago
dot dot dot the long long ago might be
you know minus ten million years or
something anyway
what's that given that you're 45 minutes
late for your four o'clock meeting whoa
yes I know I know Sandara comments
external observation is now that giving
no input this plot of a for an empty
plot like plot of a a pink bug
Geographics a Jew background to none
seems random now I see a pink plot yeah
it's making the point that the fact is
that the fact that this Pink's now is
pretty silly right because we've got all
these other things the consist
thing to do will be to pink these mean
what well if you end up generating a
plot and the plot has no meaningful data
in it or data that is specifically non
meaningful no no that's not even correct
what causes pinking why do things pink
things pink when the Fernand can't
understand them yeah I understand but
that's when the thing um Sanders saying
all these behaviors seem random that's a
bad sign that's why we're having this
meeting by the way in case you haven't
figured that out this is a a.m. we
realized there's inconsistency here
look maybe we need a larger collection
of them maybe we need to go ahead and I
mean I not even gonna guess what
chromaticity see chromaticity brought so
this is an interesting case chromaticity
plots of no elements oh that's totally
weird that's weird and that's wrong why
is that wrong because this is useful yes
plot that's the same thing so every plot
requires at least one argument graphics
does not require an argument because
it's just a container but every single
plot including list plot requires
argument okay but chromaticity plots
paints something useful even in the zero
state effectively in fact Geographics
would do the same if we enjoy that X is
not a plodding function okay and so
you're saying gee Oh list plot return
requires something yeah you're right
but chromaticity plot well
you're claiming it does the same thing
although why it didn't produce the
carrot there I don't know that means the
documentation isn't the target correctly
for some reason we can I can look at 20
seconds to fix but I have to say that I
would be not unhappy with a no argument
a special no argument forms
to sleep plot that specifically produces
rather than having to have this hack of
having no colors there to being able to
say chromaticity plot open clothes and
have it produced the color triangle
right but you did the natural arguments
the chromaticity plot or string that's
right no colors they're color spaces
right
no that colors it can be either okay
well the first two basic examples are
color spaces as artists string
completions
okay well look it seems to me that we
should simply document the chromaticity
part of no arguments gives this gives
the RGB color triangle
I wish make it do so um alright we've
clearly got more to do here I mean just
a preview we can pick this up tomorrow
well probably won't be tomorrow but but
in due course um oh my gosh there can be
look I think this needs some separate
work done of just looking at every one
of these functions and saying what does
it do when it's fed nothing or fed
things that don't make any sense I think
we're gonna find yet more
inconsistencies here unfortunately I
mean I think so I mean I think probably
my preference would be to just start
working through them and you know fix
you know implement and fix you know the
obvious things and build up the
collection of ones that need find
further discussion let's do it all right
I mean I can't even imagine something
like a raincoat chart when fed no data I
cannot even imagine what its gonna do
anybody want to guess what its gonna do
empty plot with boring axes okay no some
of the companies that exist today
existed in 1900 it's a very specific
date though yes in formatting of the
dates right okay so that's pretty random
okay all right sounds good okay thanks
to everybody thanks everybody on the
live stream thanks to everybody here see
you later